MAGGIE JOHNSON:
The way that Google
started was an academic venture.
JEFF DEAN: How do you
find interesting problems
in the world?
ALFRED SPECTOR: Google
depends on academia.
So many of the good ideas
that we've brought forward
into the world
come from academia.
JEFF DEAN: One of the real
reasons to engage with academia
is to get a really
fresh perspective.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We
empower academics
to work on real problems
and in the other direction,
academics bring ideas
and new approaches,
and are put into practice
much more quickly
than in an academic environment.
JEFF DEAN: Oh,
that's interesting,
and that's interesting,
and that's interesting.
All of the sudden,
you've knitted together
something that is really,
really tremendously powerful.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We need their
help because of the problem
we're trying to
solve internally.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Academia can
look far out into the future,
and can take greater risks and
look for really interesting
solutions that industry
sometimes cannot.
JEFF BURKE: "Grace Plains"
is a live action role-playing
game with Glass that we
developed in a class at UCLA
in the school of
Theater, Film and TV.
And it involved our students
in film, television,
digital media, and theater and
computer science Ph.D. students
working with YouTube Space with
some of the Glass developer
relations folks
and the Glass team
to mount this live
action role-playing
experience that used Glass.
This is sort of an ancient
relationship between the tools
that you have to tell
stories and the stories
that you want to tell
and how you tell them.
And so I think for
us Glass was really
a inspiration in terms of both
the themes of the story-- you
see a little bit of that in
the relationship between people
and technology in the
story-- and then also
in terms of the capabilities
of how we could bring
an audience into an
intimate interaction
with the story that
was unusual for them.
JANINE GIANFREDI: We launched
the Glass Explorer program
because we wanted to
get this new technology
in the hands of people
who are going to use it,
to experiment with it
and try new things.
We knew that
filmmakers were a group
that we wanted to
have experimenting
with the technology.
And so we announced the
Glass Creative Collective,
where we would invite several
film schools in the US
to participate in the
Explorer program with us.
Where they would
use Glass to help
us understand how it can be
used as a filmmaking tool,
as an aid for storytelling,
and, frankly, for open canvas
of all the different ways
that filmmakers and students
and faculty would
be able to help
us understand
Glass in the Space.
JEFF BURKE: We wanted
to do something
that was a role-playing
style experience,
and the story then evolved out
of a number of conversations
that were trying to look
at how could we take people
through a role-playing
experience that
was unusual and
specific to Glass
and was something original.
But it came from all
of these initial ideas
about how exciting it would
be to give people the ability
to encounter a
story as individuals
and then collectively
participate
in seeing it through.
At the Space, the
students ran pretty much
all of the production.
They did everything, from
the design of the spaces,
they shot that sort
of teaser video,
they ran all of the
video, they managed
the events and all that.
Everything that
was happening, they
were really taking the lead on.
We had students from our
Department of Film, Television
and Digital Media, and students
from our Department of Theater.
And then we had invited
some computer science
Ph.D. students to the class
to help us sort of understand
the really deep possibilities
and work with some
of the core capabilities that
we thought existed in Glass.
And so that was the
team of students
who developed the story,
and really the way
that it would unfold.
And then we tried to
bring them in contact
with other faculty
who were directing,
or new media faculty with
people that could provide advice
on the writing with the
production teams here,
and through those disciplines
all coming together
try to make a really
engaging experience.
When the opportunity
came up to try
to execute this
particular project here
we really leapt at
it, because what
it allowed us to do was to raise
the level the level not only
of the execution, but
creatively where we
could go in terms
of the technology.
And so that was an offer
that was made as a research
experiment to do here in
the context of the Space,
and we thought this
was an opportunity
that we couldn't pass up.
LIZ HARNETT: The
philosophy of the Space
is about making the production
equipment that we have here
in the facilities
accessible to anybody,
whether or not they have
a film school background
or they have any sort
of formal training.
And we're all about
experimentation
here, so the chance to do a
really cool role playing game
style experience was
something that we'd never
tried here at the Space.
The YouTube Space building
played the role of the "Grace
Plains" laboratory,
and so as soon
as participants
walked in the door
they were immersed
in this experience,
feeling as if they were entering
the actual laboratory where
these experiments
were taking place.
JEFF BURKE: This was a
really amazing opportunity
for the students to think
about how could they structure
an experience that
had pre-built elements
and then improvised elements and
then a public that you weren't
controlling.
Not exactly, right?
And so I think
what we learned is
these things can go together.
They can generate
compelling experiences
and wearable computing
Glass, in particular,
is a really nice
platform to experiment
with because of the way
you can relate individually
to every participant and
yet have them do something
collectively.
So I thought this mixture
of individual and collective
participation through the
platform was one of the things
that we learned about.
How to execute
it, that it works,
that we want to do more with it.
JANINE GIANFREDI:
I was particularly
excited to have Jeff
and his team involved
in the collective, because
they have all this development
expertise as well as the
filmmaking and theatrical
backgrounds.
And so when we
started talking, I
realized this is going to start
going in a whole new direction,
and they're going to experiment
a lot more with Glass
than we had originally
thought about when
we launched the program.
So for us, the
opportunity to have
Glass participating
in a narrative,
rather than just capturing
it, and whether that's
done through automated functions
or you have somebody actually
directing the experience
from behind the scenes
or even actually as a
participant and director,
these are opportunities with
this particular technology
that we hadn't really
set out to explore.
And we learned a ton just
watching "Grace Plains" unfold,
and also the global
brand as well.
There's all these different
ways of approaching narrative
direction and
storytelling that we're
excited to see
continue to evolve,
and more experiments
around them.
LIZ HARNETT: Having
UCLA come in,
it helped to raise the
bar for our community
and get them to think a little
bit more outside the box.
And also to inspire us and
our engineers and folks
in the product team to come up
with new features for YouTube
that are going to help
creators to tell those stories.
JEFF BURKE: I think
what's unique about Glass,
at least as we've
encountered so far,
is the relationship
to the wearer.
And that this idea of being
able to address individuals
within a context where they're
interacting with other people
is really exciting.
And the challenge of using
computing in a storytelling
experience, whether it's a
mobile device or something
else, is that there's a lot of
mediation involved between you
and other people when
you're looking at a screen.
And so the idea that you can
receive story information
or you can
participate in a story
while still being able to
interact with other people
was really exciting.
It's sort of the fundamental
capability that ultimately
was what the students
decided to explore,
in some context for a performer,
so that performer could really
continue to engage with
the world around them
while getting story
information and updates.
And in other contexts
with the public,
to have this overlay
between the interactions
they had with individuals, with
each other, and the story that
was coming to them
through Glass.
JANINE GIANFREDI: That actually
for us was really interesting.
Glass is designed to be
close to your senses,
and so you guys really
took that part of Glass
and that value of
Glass and turned it
into something beyond
what we had imagined,
which was just really
cool to see that
from so many different
participants in the experience.
JEFF BURKE: I think the notion
of interacting with performers
is very powerful and
very interesting.
And it gives us a whole
other palette of things
to try in the
context of a training
environment of a
professional school that
has performers at
the heart of it.
And I think I have a
lot of ideas, creatively
and personally, that
relate to that connection
between performers,
content, and audience,
or performers and a
story and an audience
that I think I'd like to--
I hope that we can explore.
JANINE GIANFREDI:
I hope to see it
start to become a part
of that as you plan out
what you're going to use.
Glass is one of those tools, in
part because of the perspective
you get wearing Glass,
the fact that it
is close to your senses, and
the fact that you can engage
a subject in a
really different way.
But I also hope to see
Glass used more in the way
that Jeff's group did, which
is really getting inputs
from somebody and then
reacting to them as an actor.
Or maybe not as an actor, but
as a participant in there.
So again, I had never
really thought of it
as being a part of the story.
I thought it was going to
be a bit in the backdrop.
And so we really want
to see more of that
as it continues to evolve.
And the other piece that's
been really exciting
about the Creative Collective is
we've gotten a lot of feedback
on the product itself, and
how it works really well,
and some of the
challenges that are
encountered when using
it for storytelling.
And so that's helping us think
through further iterations
and improvements we
can make, and things
that we can change
and shift a bit.
JEFF DEAN: If you
want to hear more
about "Grace Plains"
and the other projects
that we did with
Glass at UCLA, stay
tuned for the tech talk
at YouTube Space LA.